précision n'a pas fait mais recule pas
le président a un peu tendance à
toujours considéré que ce qui a été fait
et est toujours parfait il a même dit à
un moment
finalement nous n'aurons manqué de rien
c'était dur mais 2020 et je pense soyez
vous que la confiance que les français
dans la parole publique qui est un peu
écornée aujourd'hui et donc leur
capacité à participer à la lutte contre
le coc vide est aussi écorné par la
difficulté qu'ils ont à comprendre et à
accepter les offres qui sont donnés et
c'est vrai que le président aurait dit
simplement bah oui c'est vrai nous
n'étions pas prêts au mois de mars
c'est vrai c'est de ma faute parce que
c'est ce que vous sous-entendez non pas
du tout aujourd'hui dit il faut
réfléchir au fait d'avoir s excuser ce
serait reconnaître que c'est en partie
sa faute non non vous allez d'abord
c'est un sujet extrêmement complexe il
n'y a pas un individu dos et la faute
sinon ça serait plus trop simple je
pense que c'est une affaire très
complexe mais que les pouvoirs publics
aient failli dans la préparation au mois
de mars dans l'impréparation un an plus
tard un an plus tard d'une étions
toujours pas préparés que les pouvoirs
publics aient failli dans les
instructions qu'ils nous ont donnée
souvenez vous à une époque quand on nous
expliquait qu'il ne fallait pas porter
de masque ce n'était pas nécessaire et
que c'était même difficile tous ces
éléments là ont nui à la parole publique
et il ya un moment où fond et bien les
gens ne croient plus qu'on leur dit je
vous donnais le témoignage du maire de
séoul
le maire de séoul très peu de victimes à
séoul on lui demandait mais au fond
qu'est ce qui a marché chez vous vous
aviez plus de tests vous aviez plus de
lits de réanimation maire de séoul a dit
non vous n'avez pas compris ce qui a
marché chez nous c'était la confiance
les gens nous ont fait confiance moi je
crois que la confiance par passe aussi
par la reconnaissance d'un certain
nombre des ravins typiquement dans les
semaines et les mois qui vont arriver
la question va être la question des
variants il faut tout faire pour que à
la fois n'y ait pas de variants qui
apparaissent sur notre territoire
c'est un sujet qu'on abordera peut-être
après qui est fondamentale et pour faire
en sorte que les variants qui sont à
l'extérieur n'entre pas donc il faut
contrôler les frontières
en fait ce qu'il faut faire c'est ce que
font les britanniques quand vous arrivez
sur le territoire en grande bretagne
vous devez avoir un test pcr négatif
vous devez payer pour un deuxième test
vous payez vous même pour un deuxième
test au deuxième jour et pour un
troisième test au huitième jour et si
c'est positif
vous payez vous même pour la recherche
du variant ce qu'on appelle le
séquençage et enfin on vous demande de
vous isoler dans un hôtel dont vous
payer tous les frais tout ça sanctionné
par un coup de fil
tous les jours d'une autre
et et sanitaires quelconque qui vérifie
que tout va bien que vous êtes bien de
votre talent et si vous avez le malheur
de ne pas respecter ces mesures c'est
onze ou douze mille euros damende donc
je crois que c'est ça qu'il faut faire
donc on est en dessous la maison je ne
sais pas en fait le premier ministre
fait une annonce qui est bonne dire
qu'il faut des tests de l'isolément et
éventuellement une amende
jean castex vuli bravo la question c'est
comme toujours c'est quelle est la
nature réelle de la promesse qu'ils
aient fait parce qu'on a eu des tas de
promesses dans le passé sur des tas de
mesures intelligentes mais c'est une
chose de dire qu'on va faire c'en est
une autre de voir ce qu'on vaut donc moi
je pose la question
isolement dans quelles conditions le
contrôle dans quelles conditions les
tests dans quelles conditions
voilà enfin c'est simple que cela